-Performing "Tail Lights,"
featuring Morray,
from his new album, "Ben,"
give it up for Macklemore!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-♪ I see a fork in the road ♪
♪ I don't know
what path I'm taking ♪
♪ But my compass is broke ♪
♪ And I don't know
if I'mma make it ♪
♪ Yeah, yeah ♪
♪ Told a lot of lies,
pushed the love aside ♪
♪ Tried to drive away,
but my hands are tied ♪
♪ Never giving up,
always stay and fight ♪
♪ For me ♪
-♪ I been driving this road ♪
♪ I been driving this road ♪
♪ Uh-huh, fork in the middle,
got two choices to go ♪
♪ Give the kids a kiss for me
if I don't make it home ♪
♪ When I was growing up,
we didn't have a diagnosis ♪
♪ We just kept taking more
to get the serotonin ♪
♪ Got older and all of my homies
overdosing ♪
♪ Therapy wasn't an option
to process our emotions ♪
♪ Mama always said,
"What you afraid of, boy? ♪
♪ Everything's good,
you got angels, boy" ♪
♪ Closed mouths go hungry,
better raise your voice ♪
♪ God-sized hole,
no replacing the void ♪
♪ We create out of chaos ♪
♪ Music is a séance ♪
♪ Land that
our ancestors' graves on ♪
♪ My favorite artists
are my two little girls ♪
♪ I see freedom firsthand ♪
♪ In what they make
with their crayons ♪
♪ Light, it was always on glow ♪
♪ And when I was lost,
I was on the right road ♪
♪ Tail lights ahead
as I drive slow ♪
♪ Just a right turn,
then I find my way home ♪
-♪ I see a fork in the road ♪
-Let's go.
-♪ I don't know
what path I'm taking ♪
♪ But my compass is broke ♪
♪ And I don't know
if I'mma make it ♪
♪ Yeah, yeah ♪
♪ Told a lot of lies,
pushed the love aside ♪
♪ Tried to drive away,
but my hands are tied ♪
♪ Never giving up,
always stay and fight ♪
♪ For me ♪
♪ I'll follow your tail lights ♪
♪ To wherever they may lead ♪
♪ I'll try and match
your speed ♪
-♪ Now, Virgil said that when
you make it to the penthouse ♪
♪ It's your duty to send
the elevator back down ♪
♪ Somewhere along the highway
I got lost ♪
♪ And I realized that God
was ahead of me all along ♪
♪ My mind on my business ♪
♪ Grind my only mission
most high ♪
♪ The messenger wasn't
quiet enough to listen ♪
♪ My time was occupied when even
dining with my children ♪
♪ It's like me, myself, and I,
and I lost sight of the vision ♪
♪ On borrowed time,
living in extra innings ♪
♪ Industry survives,
I'm glorifying the millions ♪
♪ The playlists and the streams,
album bundles and tees ♪
♪ They cannot manufacture
what resides in the spirit ♪
♪ The phantom ain't enough
if you don't remember ♪
♪ All of the countless rides
in the Civic ♪
♪ The moments of failure
that preceded this ♪
♪ Not giving a damn about
other people's perception ♪
♪ That's what freedom is ♪
♪ And that's what
I'mma teach my kids ♪
♪ Any moment peace
is available ♪
♪ You just gotta remember
to breathe it in ♪
♪ And finally
I can breathe again ♪
♪ Anyway, man,
I'mma roll the dice ♪
♪ Got the wheel regardless
of where I go in life ♪
♪ I know tonight
it was always on glow ♪
♪ And when I was lost,
I was on the right road ♪
♪ Tail lights ahead
as I drive slow ♪
♪ Just a right turn,
then I find my way home ♪
-♪ I see a fork in the road ♪
-Let's go.
-♪ I don't know
what path I'm taking ♪
♪ But my compass is broke ♪
♪ And I don't know
if I'mma make it ♪
♪ Yeah, yeah ♪
♪ Told a lot of lies,
pushed the love aside ♪
♪ Tried to drive away,
but my hands are tied ♪
♪ Never giving up,
always stay and fight ♪
♪ For me ♪
♪ I'll follow your tail lights ♪
♪ To wherever they may lead ♪
♪ I'll try and match
your speed ♪
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]